the episode opens up in Botswana with
the narrator mentioning that animals
once Ruled the Earth and what if they
finally decided to take it back
following this Abraham Kenyatta a safari
guide at kitsuko Safari Camp can be seen
preparing for an early morning Safari
ride for the tourists he enters his camp
and notices his nephew watching videos
of a scientist Robert Oz revealing that
his latest experiments have concluded
something shocking soon all animals from
around the world will change and stop
obeying humans they will hunt down all
humans until they are wiped off the face
of the Earth meanwhile Abraham wakes up
his partner who also happens to be
Robert's son Jackson and asks him to get
ready for a safari ride after a while
the two hop on their Safari Jeep and
guide a group of tourists through the
grasslands along the way they notice a
Trophy Hunter trying to shoot a rhino
but Jackson cleverly plays loud music
and scares the animal away hence foiling
the Hunter's plan the scene then shifts
to Los Angeles where two men come out of
a bar and try to relieve themselves
around a corner suddenly two lie ions
appear out of nowhere and Gobble them up
the following day a news reporter at La
Telegraph Jamie Campbell watches the
news of lions escaping from the city zoo
and killing three people following some
research she learns that the lion
started acting strangely after they were
fed Food Supplies from Raiden Global a
biotechnology company that evening as
Jaime is conducting an interview she
gets to know that several cats from the
neighborhood have gone missing in recent
days the next morning Jamie visits the
zoo and meets Veterinary pathologist
Mitch Morgan after a quick chat Mitch
takes her to his lab and dismisses her
suspicion that the food from Raiden
Global caused the Lions to be violent he
also reveals that the Lions have since
been put down as they had become too
dangerous to tame before he leaves Jaime
informs him about the missing cats in
Botswana Jackson and Abraham fly to
Macy's Mako camp and get shocked to find
it completely deserted not even a single
tourist or staff member is present just
then Jackson finds a video camera lying
on the ground when he plays it he sees
the tourists running away from something
side they discover a single Lion's
footprint and become confused how a
solitary animal could scare a hundred
people away sensing that something bad
might have happened the two set off to
search for the tourists after a while
they find a boss stopped in the middle
of the tall grass field both the guides
grab a rifle and get out of their
vehicle with Abraham asking Jackson to
stay behind and look out for him when
Abraham enters the boss suddenly a woman
walks out of the tall grass and
approaches Jackson she nervously
mentions that they should run and just
then a lion enters the bus and attacks
Abraham Jackson is devastated to hear
his best friend screams but before he
can help a bunch of other Lions show up
as a result he reluctantly gets into his
Jeep and drives away with the woman
leaving his friend to die on their way
the woman introduces herself as a French
tourist Chloe and reveals about how she
and her group got attacked by a group of
lions when they were out to see gazelles
unfortunately their day goes from bad to
worse when the Jeep suddenly breaks down
with the camp still six miles away
Jackson suggests they walk to the camp
camp but Chloe is afraid as she has seen
the barbaric man eating lions however
when Jackson assures her that Lions do
not attack when they are full she
reluctantly agrees after a while as the
two are walking alongside a river they
are approached by yet another group of
lions the duo freezes in horror and when
one of the Lions comes near them Jackson
notices that its eyes have defiant
pupils this apparently means that the
lion is dangerous and right then Jackson
and Chloe slip and fall from a small
Cliff fortunately they are not injured
and they make it safely to Camp there
Jackson hypothesizes that his father
Robert Oz was right all along the
animals have started acting crazy hence
he immediately calls the Botswana Center
for a research and Rescue Team back in
La Jaime receives a message from Mitch
mentioning that he has found the missing
cats she immediately drives off and
finds him waiting for her at an
elementary school through her surprise
Mitch shows her a tree full of cats and
assumes that they are being controlled
by something strange Jaime wastes no
time and calls animal rescue while Mitch
finds a small honeysuckle plant under
the tree surprisingly when he picks up
the plant all the cats climb down the
tree and walk away in Botswana the
rescue team finally arrives at the camp
but instead of helping they arrest
Jackson for interfering with lawful
hunting meanwhile a few kilometers away
a lion drags a lifeless Abraham up a
tree while the other Lions simply watch
the next day Jackson somehow gets out of
prison by pleading with the guard
kavimba that he has to go he explains
that something strange is happening
outside and that they have to solve it
before the situation gets worse hearing
this kavimba also decides to accompany
him when Jackson steps out of the prison
he meets Chloe ready to leave for Paris
they exchange numbers before departing
next Jackson and kavimba along with a
Jeep driver visit the place where
Abraham was attacked by the Lions before
they notice a trail of blood and after
following it find Abraham lying on a
tree disregarding the danger Jackson
rushes to save his friend while the
other two follow him closely
surprisingly Abraham is still alive and
he tries to warn Jackson about the Lions
the groups somehow manages to place him
in the Jeep and at the same time the
pride of male lions also arrives however
they do not attack the humans and simply
watch them leave it appears as if they
wanted the humans to leave in the next
scene the men have already arrived at
the camp where Jackson's mother
Elizabeth Oz is looking after the
injured people she reveals to Jackson
that Abraham is absolutely fine with no
lacerations or bite marks on his body
after a while he wakes up and Jackson
pays him a visit on inquiring Abraham
reveals that when he entered the tourist
boss a male lion sneaked in and knocked
him out with a single swipe the next
thing he remembers is being dragged to
the tree branch hearing this Jax
introduces that the lions were never
going to eat Abraham but were instead
waiting for others to find him he then
assumes that the Lions want to spread a
message to the human world that they are
now no longer afraid the scene then
shifts to Slovenia where a British
couple is trying to adopt a Slovak kid
since they are on a few days trial the
husband Nicholas tries his best to keep
the boy happy he takes the boy to zoos
buys him toys and take takes care of his
every need that night a dog sneakily
grabs the boy's toy and runs away
prompting Nicholas to go after it a few
minutes later he reaches a dark alley
and finally catches the dog but when he
takes a proper look around the place
Nicholas notices several mutilated
bodies lying around terrified he tries
running away but a bunch of angry dogs
surround him and finish him off back in
Los Angeles Jaime does some research and
learns that Raiden Global is actually
using harmful chemicals while
manufacturing their food products she
then visits Mitch and tells him that she
suspects the chemical is the instigator
of the animal's violent attack it turns
out that all the lions in the city have
started being somewhat violent after a
while they meet with a zoo worker and
convince her to provide them with a lion
cub so that they can study it and find
the cause of their aberrant Behavior
soon Jamie and Mitch start their
research by sedating the cub and hooking
it up to several wires but before they
can come up with anything conclusive the
lion cub wakes up this shocks match as
the sedative was supposed to work for a
further two hours at the same same time
he gets a call from the zoo worker from
before informing him that all the lions
in the zoo have started roaring
aggressively when Mitch adds everything
up he concludes that somehow the Lions
have started to communicate long
distance using unusual hyper gamma
frequencies
how did he figure that out in Botswana
Jack's mom Elizabeth examines all the
dead tourists and figures out that they
have all been finished off in a
different fashion compared to what lions
normally do usually lines go for The
Knack and inflict a quick death but in
this instance the victims have severed
carotid arteries implying that they have
died in agonizingly slow death Elizabeth
immediately summons her son and tells
him that the animals have started to
change something which his father Robert
had predicted long ago it turns out that
Robert was an avid animal researcher and
in particular he focused on their
behavior he knew that the animals would
soon turn sadly none of his colleagues
or family members believed him and
instead just called him names Elizabeth
then tells Jackson to visit Japan and
retrieve his father's research materials
as that's where he spent his final years
though she hated him before she believes
that Robert's theory is coming true and
they need to know about it and control
it before it causes more destruction
Jackson immediately agrees to go and
banged up Abraham also joins him
following this we are taken to Paris
where the French tourists from earlier
Chloe is shown she turns out to be an
intelligence Analyst at dgse which is
the equivalent of the British MI6 or the
American CIA after work as Chloe gets
ready to depart she is approached by a
sketchy guy in a suit named Gaspard
Alves he appears to know everything
about her including how she survived a
lion attack in Botswana he explains
about how animals around the world have
become violent and erratic to prove his
assumptions at first he takes her to a
morgue where the dog attack victims have
been brought realizing that they don't
have much time left and because of
Chloe's vast skill set he wants her to
Aid him in his investigation meanwhile
Jackson and Abraham reach Tokyo and meet
Monaco the second wife of Robert Jackson
informs her that they are here to
retrieve the research materials from his
father but menaka replies that she
doesn't have them she reveals that
everything is kept safe on a secluded
Island near Fukushima nuclear Center
wasting no time the group leaves for
Fukushima on a private plane minako
hands the boys a geiger counter a device
to measure radiation saying the place is
still not safe to visit just then the
plane is attacked by a swarm of bats
Jackson is shocked to see bats flying at
such a high altitude not to mention in
the daytime unfortunately the plane
loses control and crashes into the sea
killing Monaco and the pilot Jackson and
Abraham are devastated by the incident
but nonetheless they decide to explore
the island before help arrives after
some hours of walking they finally come
across Robert's Research Place strangely
they also find some horses that have
their eyes gouged out later after
entering the main research house Abraham
discovers the horse's eyes kept inside a
glass jar they then play some of the
research videos where Robert mentions
that the horses have become aggressive
he even talks about their defiant pupils
with this Abraham and Jackson conclude
that Robert blinded the horses when they
became aggressive on the other hand the
sketchy suit guy from earlier Gaspard
approaches Mitch and requests that they
work together to find out about the
changing animal behavior Mitch agrees
straight away but on one condition Jaime
will also join them in the next scene
Gaspard and his team arrive at Shima
Island and rescue Abraham and Jackson
They then reach a building in Tokyo
where Mitch and Jamie have already
arrived following this Gaspard
introduces the four to Mr Delavan the
head of the secret animal behavior
investigation Delavan shows them some
clips from around the world where
different animals are attacking and
killing humans he then asserts that the
animal pandemic has begun and they need
to act fast before it can cause more
damage at last he summons the leader of
the team who is none other than Chloe we
are then taken to Mississippi where a
prisoner Evan Lee Hartley is about to be
executed for killing a number of hunters
around the area but strangely before the
procedure can take place a pack of
aggressive wolves enter the prison and
kill everyone on site except for Evan
for some reason they appear to be
submissive to him the following day
Chloe suggests that the entire group
remain classified and to travel to
Mississippi to gather information about
the wolf attack when they arrive she
assigns Abraham and Mitch to catch a
wolf for research purposes and asks the
others to accompany her to the prison
the group is skeptical about her
decisions but nonetheless they agree at
the prison Chloe meets Deputy Kraft and
agent Ben from the FBI while Chloe and
craft are conversing Jackson takes a
closer look at the CCTV footage of the
attack and sees that the death row
prisoner Evan Lee was mysteriously
controlling a wolf having been out there
warging following this the group walks
out of the prison with Jackson stating
that the Wolves need an alpha leader to
control them he then assumes that the
alpha leader is Evan Lee later at night
Jaime researches Heavenly and finds that
he had no criminal background until 2008
when he stabbed a group of hunters to
death for no conclusive reason the next
day Abraham and Mitch go to a nearby
Forest while Chloe Jackson and Jaime are
at the prison area looking around the
Wolves Footprints and their tracks
Jackson discovers that the Wolves
entered the prison by digging holes
underneath the metal fence and also
helped Evan Lee escape on the other hand
as Mitch and Abraham are wandering
through the forest Heavenly and his pack
of wolves surround them but fortunately
before he can do something bad Evan
hears a wolf howling and runs towards it
leaving mentioned Abraham on harmed
meanwhile Jaime interviews an
acquaintance of Evan Lee and learns that
he has always had a Bible on him which
supposedly has some writings on it so
Jaime returns to the prison with a fake
Alias and goes straight to Evan's former
cell after searching for a bit she
eventually finds the Bible and takes it
with her on the other hand Jackson and
Chloe also Unite with Mitch and Abraham
together they decide to leave with an
injured wolf that was recently shot by
the hunters the scene then shifts to the
hotel room where the group is trying to
treat the injured wolf and find out the
reason for its aggressive behavior after
some research Mitch states that the wolf
is infected with a harmful bacteria
which he believes is responsible for
their change in Behavior he then
prepares a chemical solution and
proceeds to test it with the wolf's
blood if the mixture starts reacting and
showing bubbles this will prove his
theory that the bacteria is the culprit
lo and behold the blood reacts so
violently that it causes the experiment
vessel to explode later agent Ben from
the FBI visits their room and informs
Chloe that the deputy is on his way to
interrogate her team but before he can
arrive the group packs their belongings
and leaves in the last scene a group
meets Jaime at the parking lot where she
hands over the Bible she found earlier
Jaime also says that Evan Lee has
underlined all the animal references in
it just then Chloe pulls out a photo of
Evan Lee with another person from the
Bible Jackson is shocked by the picture
as the man next to Evan Lee is none
other than his own father Robert to see
what happens next watch the second part
in series recapped